foreign
[Music]
nasher's power is critical for closing
out the map sometimes it's earned the
flip of a coin could just decide it all
and it comes up heads for b-l-g
sometimes
does xdg have the focus to pull this
fighter favor Cruiser goes down to
manually explain these big there with a
double kill cutie pie dig why did you go
for Baron and the unique importance of
the game's most powerful objective means
that securing Baron is a crucial skill
for approach jungler he's got absolutely
no Manner and Tall has to be the hero
can he get the flux in here as he is
going to use the realm walk blank he's
gonna get in there that got Baron again
whether securing it or stealing it an 80
carry being
the old look or the news
this is the story of Baron Nasher
[Applause]
[Music]
in the earliest days of League of
Legends Baron Nasher was a neutral
objective that gave the team that killed
it a global buff called exalted with
Baron Nasher but the name itself is even
older than that it comes from League's
progenitor defense of the Ancients there
and later in Dota 2 Roshan was a
powerful neutral enemy and Nasher is its
anagram initially the exalted with Baron
Nasher buff was a three-minute increase
to attack damage and ability power the
buff was substantial so even back then
Baron was an objective that had to be
contested but taking Baron is a risk he
hammers away at nearby Champions so if
the other team shows up it's bound to
get hectic AAA knows they've been
spotted now but can they get it in time
it's going to be close and I'm not quite
sure it is yet started and it's it's
grabbed by fnatic isn't good shape for
them at least the other fight's gonna
turn out looks like Kuja already dead
yes are getting crushed right now by
shushay and the rest and this was
looking so good dramatic right now it
wasn't until the pre-season patch for
season five when summoner's Rift
underwent a bunch of changes that Baron
changed too like before he hammered
nearby Champions by attacking them with
a number of abilities but he looked
different and spawned at the 15 minute
Mark most importantly though since it
now empowered nearby minions the baron
buff became focused around pushing down
the enemy base making it even more
critical barenbach arguably much more
powerful than it is on live still gives
you the attack damage and ability power
you no longer get the regen but it makes
you recall twice as fast and now most
importantly Buffs all of your nearby
minis you kind of like carry the aura to
them right they're leading your army
yeah so why do we make this change and
what real impact is this going to have
especially with how much teams already
put on Baron right now for me I feel
like the baron buff of the new season is
one of the most terrifying changes us
too but potentially the best change from
my experience playing with it what this
does is the baron buff isn't actually
making the minions do much more damage
it's just making it so they actually
give you time to hit the turret so if a
team gets Barren they have an absolute
opportunity to finish the game and they
need to take that chance because they're
not going to be able to Siege out if
they got poked back it's not if they can
heal up they're gonna have to go back
really really scary big things like this
okay like right there's no way to know
exactly how it's going to turn out until
we start seeing it over the course of
like hundreds of games or something like
not even hundreds obviously thousands
because of how you know popular league
is but you get what I'm saying since
Baron was such an important part of
League meta it's fitting then that one
of the most impressive dynasties in the
game's history would develop a
reputation for inevitable wins and that
often meant Baron was involved between
2013 and 2017 SK Telecom T1 showed a
level of Excellence that was difficult
for opponents to match they won three
World Championships and their reputation
for dominance grew well if there's
anything that skp shown it's the ability
to cultivate new Talent as they take
another very easy Baron and Roman's like
yep yep I'm getting ready to Hoist the
big check particularly from 2015 onward
Baron was a key objective to be seized
and SKT made sure that their opponents
knew that taking it when they were on
the rift would never be easy qg are
setting up for Baron wolf and bang bang
just towards the outside Heroes will
they need to hold this one up tippet
fight comes in only two qg players
caught in that one here the rest are
free to fight and that's why blankie
wolf have to see right on back oh my
Lord skp steal the baron incredible
stuff and Uzi drops down now bang might
be caught though he needs to try and cut
back back is doing all the work it's a
triple kill okay all right they're gonna
go for the very now immediately go over
the baron right now because Duke is so
dangerous in the current position
they're going for it all right they grab
pure can they get this bear in here
burn a little bit low watch is coming in
being able to use Embrace Baron getting
lower gets taken by SKT they're gonna
turn onto Naja now watch in a bit of
trouble you're barring in the back lines
and goon can't get too close big
explosive cast splits him up can they
Skirmish bang with the kill there watch
gonna go down his own thing he gets one
here in the back lines another it's a
double kill for bang SKT somehow some
way they found a chance well that's
gonna be a baron for janair should be
yeah Jin air did the right thing they
immediately altered Faker with lissandro
Hall and it focused him instead yep well
uh Duke and bang actually causing a lot
of damage here oh Duke's gonna pick up
one kill that Baron sells half Health
here bang doing work in the pit right
now Trace tries to go for the talk
misses it bang still has his flash
that's a double kill for Duke that's a
triple kill for Duke he's going for
another one guzan has to flash out Trace
still there
because I'm using the E to get out
actually and SK Telecom Here Comes wolf
he can take that Baron oh my God
sucked out of it they're an MVP but SK
Telecom still going to be able to take
it what a turnaround why did Baron seem
to favor SKT so much well much of their
era was about team fighting and in this
respect they were Peerless even if they
somehow fell behind it seemed like the
team could always find the perfect route
through a skirmish so naturally a lot of
the time Baron loomed over A Game's
finale another factor to consider was
the incredible lineup of junglers
fielded by SKT during this time bengi
blank and later peanut were all big
names that consistently shown around the
baron pit throughout their careers he's
got absolutely no matter in towel has to
be the hero
can he get the flux in here as he is
going to use the realm or blank he's
gonna get into it thank God damn Baron
again but not every team had the same
success around the baron pit while it
was a place you went to finish the game
things often could and did go wrong and
in the highest pressure moments some
teams even developed a reputation for
failing in Baron's Shadow now the
question is do they have to try to rush
this down it's getting pretty low the
Israel ultimate is going to cross there
comes Kane he's gonna go shooting
there's good he should be able to get
the crescendo down the baron has gone
down and Scott Dickens has the picks up
the baron they managed to get in there
haven't they got the damage to imagine
saw the two the team find Scarlet's
gonna get dropped eventually there goes
Cara I've been cutie pie just up and
decide have they got the damage song
hasn't done anything available
but he gets stunned up he can't get the
last hit down they're going for it with
a blue buff karpus karthus right now and
here comes the rest of the team mashed
me enzymes partner running across Gente
puts the ball down can he get another
miraculous Shockwave and of course
keeping it coming in from the back Baron
losing more Health down to a thousand
Health oh my gosh Nintendo steals it and
there's the Shockwave do they have the
damage scarra does not have Sonia's
North Sarah well they get the pain down
Gente forced to flash away crumbs in and
here comes kiwi kid as well who's got
the damage Nintendo's up in the front he
would get kind of a low to the front
line instead of getting burnt down they
find one kill even before Baron had a
new look and a new buff dignitas or
dignitas as they were sometimes
mockingly called were finding Brave new
ways to lose the game at Baron this is
the point where you make a risky call
this you have to choose if you want to
end the game oh dear they're going for
it this is still very risky the three
members of xcg might be enough to
contest this if they just wait around
and poke them inside the turret they
could cause dignitas to be very scared
and abort their mission
Baron looking a little low here they do
want to abort Kobe they're going on to
blood water Zuna comes up from the
backside that's some low XP bars on Dick
does xdg have the focus to pull this
fight their favor Cruiser goes down
immediately Xfinity's big there with a
double kill cutie pie dig why did you go
for Baron basically the baron pit was
the flagpole and the rest of the LCS and
the world were bullying dignitas there
this happens so often compilations were
made as far back as 2014. and dignitas's
notorious Baron troubles quickly became
an enduring meme that outlasted the
org's initial time in the LCS all right
talk to me about that first game you
guys in the driver's seat the entire
game and then the right when I think you
guys got the game in the bag you lose
inhib Baron at the same time so what
were you guys thinking what were you
guys doing I mean dignitas is out of the
LCS now so Somebody's gotta take the
reins in terms of Baron throws and we
decided that's going to be us so for the
past four or so weeks we've just been
throwing it Baron throwing it Baron
throwing it Baron and we thought we'd
just continue to streak here today even
car's got a Little Help from Baron from
time to time though and they have all
the time in the world here to trade for
blue dare I mean you don't trade this
because you're axis will die no your
Nexus will die the baron takes too long
to kill what are they thinking that's
Bad News Bears I do not know where that
call just came okay
that's gonna put the nail in the coffin
and after being on their heels for the
past seven minutes dignitas is gonna
take down the Nexus to win their first
game of the North American Spring split
and sure dignitas might have been the
most obvious example but the truth is
that Baron is about closing out the game
less experienced teams might show off
flashy plays early in the match but when
it's time to close out against veteran
squads a Barren throw exposes the cracks
in the foundation we don't really have
like the right play in our mind that we
need to make to actually close out the
game like we can get we can get these
leads all the time but then like it's
super easy to throw at Baron because
you're in the driver's seat completely
but yet it can always be there's always
such a chance for like a 50 50 with
Smite right whether it was possible or
not for a team to successfully use Baron
to win it was never a sure bet for
anyone because as long as there's one
person alive especially the jungler
Anything could happen around the pit and
while the very best teams in the world
have always tried to make Baron a sure
thing sometimes that's just not possible
sometimes you have to roll the dice and
it's always been that way all they have
to do is stand within that queue if he
gets it he's get that percent damage
into the Smite and it's quite hard to
dodge but look at that I'll just make a
human wall here shot coming in they
could get the pole on they do oh no they
do not oh my God there's the burn The
Shield's gonna wear off at the time oh
the ultimate goes across he gets out
with 108 oh blood water steals
Baron with him I don't even know with a
rake one tornado if there was one
constant around Baron as an objective it
was the idea of the baron 50 50. can
they take the fight sayos now going in
on his shot leaving back right over the
wall the shutdown is huge on demand and
plg might have just thrown everything
away absolute patience in the face of
disaster the flip of a coin could just
decide it all and it comes up heads for
p l g if both junglers were alive at a
comparable level and near the pit then
either one could Smite the last of
Baron's hit points to secure it and that
means that both were trying to pull a
frame perfect trigger as the fight raged
around them
rarely be in favor of talking Sports can
hacker find some kind of Miracle steel
though chaos
back in the pit because let's find down
Shelton went in and out and I'll tell
you what's like going into a Kmart in
pink season Ultra Prime and flood
disciple the Peter has to flush away top
B's both making a one for one but shout
out what an absolute baller and with
jungler so used to playing round Baron
even the smallest miscalculation could
be fatal but it's not always the
junglers either any Champion that can
reach out and hurt the baron can steal
it and so certain players became known
for having this Killer Instinct that's
stealing a baron requires like umayushi
who stole two of them in a critical
series is gonna have to disrupt a lot
here carry a look at his own barrel away
Jeff pulls him right back
definitely
[Applause]
just stole Barrett TRX Circle T1 like
shocks foreign
[Applause]
comes in he must just about see it
the arrow of a lifetime
still of a lifetime from dubayushi
that's twice in this series he's done it
sometimes Baron Steels have even allowed
established narratives to change and for
new stories to take root like when smeb
made history leading rocks to their
first domestic finals win can they take
it out though it's still risky even with
peanut down
is up remember rocks tigers fighting for
their tournament life here fighting for
prep for their team like Baron taken oh
taken by Smith oh man stole the baron
they're going after fly now and rock
slangers turning it around and Johnny so
low
he did it in a game that has always been
about snowballing lead about grinding
your opponent down Baron remains a place
where sometimes none of that matters
where everyone from your silver
teammates to the very best players in
the world just have to come up clutch
and despite incremental changes and
shifting metas Baron has remained much
the same as it always has even in a game
that changes as often as League of
Legends it has been a constant a pillar
of the map and strategy and team fights
since the very beginning but even now in
2023 games are often decided at Baron at
MSI in the midst of a meta that's
centered on intense team fighting the
baron pit saw plenty of Bloodshed Cloud9
committing to the baron for now still
the members on the wall where's the
poppy at the barrel it's going to be
stolen away by the golden Guardians
they've already found a kill on flapper
and now they're gonna find fudge as well
G2 were not able to find him this time
still a little bit risky if it's
unhinged pretty low but caps does not
have he can kill everybody
has teleport available 10 seconds on him
coming back into this fight T1 they know
it they want to try and get this turned
soon but the knock-up on to zayas he's
taking so much damage here from Genji
but it's a phenomenal nominal from owner
will secure the baron this guy's poppy
has been absurd this game just like the
weird void-borne creature that took the
shape of a river serpent Baron has
formed its own identity over the years
Baron served as an epic backdrop to some
of the game's greatest ever moments
careers were made and unmade hopes Rose
and fell in the shadow of the serpent
and because its Ware games are lost and
heroes are forged fans and hopefuls know
that when you step into the pit any
mistake can be fatal and bear and Nasher
is the one that'll decide your fate
[Applause]
I think